I received a very interesting email from
a neuroscientist this week and this
neuroscientist said you know David you
should just look at the verbal symptoms
of schizophrenia rather than dementia or
drug abuse to explain Donald Trump's
behavior and I want to dig right into
this now let me put the disclaimer right
out there I am NOT a neuroscientist
I am NOT coming up with any of this
stuff and I am NOT diagnosing Trump with
anything what I'm doing is pointing out
we've been looking at Trump's brain
glitches his speech patterns his bizarre
behavior his walking away from his limo
when it was right in front of him he's
not seeing Rudy Giuliani when Rudy
Giuliani was right in front of him
talking about the oranges of an
investigation Hef Safa hide all of that
stuff right we have heard from
professionals who say it's cognitive
decline we've heard from professionals
who say it's dementia we've heard it
could be a side effect of medication
could be drug abuse okay a lot of
different ideas a neuroscientist wrote
to me and said David look at the
language disturbances that are outlined
in schizophrenia and just see what you
think so I did it
peer-reviewed journal article from this
year journal is called current opinions
on psychiatry the article is called
anomalies or anomalies both are valid
pronunciations anomalies in language as
a biomarker for schizophrenia and it
says that impaired verbal communication
is one of the key diagnostic features of
schizophrenia spectrum disorders and it
lists the following traits and I have to
tell you Trump does seem to experience
every single one of these difficulties
with lexical selection and retrieval
Trump has that issue disturbances in
priming and reduced syntactic priming
trumpet has that reduced proactive
inhibition difficulties with coherently
generating a narrative Trump can't
maintain a coherent narrative when he
speaks
using neologisms word approximation
disturbances in cohesion vague
references missing information and
confuse
references it's like it's describing
Trump speech sentences with reduced
syntactic complexity less dependence and
embedded clauses and use fewer
connective markers that is Donald
Trump's simplistic childish speech
described to a tee compared with normal
speech the speech of those experiencing
schizophrenia
contains more hesitations pauses and
longer pauses that's Trump intonation is
flat and monotonous that is Trump we've
actually talked about you know we say
when when Trump talks about the number
of deaths and cases and the the the
tragedy and suffering of coronavirus we
notice he seems to completely lack
empathy it also interpreted differently
could be what the biomarkers the verbal
biomarkers of schizophrenia described as
a flat monotonous intonation so I'm not
bringing this to you as a diagnosis I am
NOT coming up with this what I'm telling
you is a neuroscientist pointed out look
at this just take a look at it and see
if it fits and boy does it fit let me
know your thoughts we will take a quick
break and follow up on this very very
soon I want to give a quick shout out to
one of our sponsors VIN Charo watches
they're giving my audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch maybe you don't
usually wear a watch and you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out VIN Charo it's an American
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even Cheryl watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the kairos in white and
silver really loved the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really loved this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing Aven Chara
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch